pounds gum res minutes welcome welcome
welcome welcome there's a lot of change
of the past 20 years
what would it look like in another 2000
hi how about the future okay you me no
way how does that work
drag and drop a photo to episode uh hang
on Bruce this is so exciting I always
wanted to talk to myself in pewter I
don't know anything insane that's
perfect
that's a perfect right there right
[ __ ] there I am a FEMA foot what I'm
a male why do I feel like my face is
getting molested by a robot I'm so
curious how dead uh that's it it's like
she by surprise what is that what is
that a Maya demon I knew it I knew I was
part of Illuminati no wait wait are you
saying something hello my skull you
should mention that
what why do I have a British accent shut
up our dog yes our dog guess what yes so
could a dog the a new net yeah I don't
need it
that our show shut up evil skin Wiles
Edgar I'm so sorry I would never replace
it with that little [ __ ] I don't need a
caller to know that my dog only wants
ass can we cyber kiss that's a good
question I don't understand this line of
questioning you should be thankful
anyone wanna kiss that face oh you're
the best
oh stop it you're the best it's there no
plastic surgery in the future is that
really all you're interested right there
is a legitimate question now let's
retake the picture I can't I can't
I'm sorry I can't deal with your face I
don't want to talk to myself in the
future this awkward oh that's can pretty
well
Oh God okay ah hi there ah let's look at
Ryan Higa dead uh oh god what let's try
that one again huh me huh this is my new
favorite game let's take a look at uh
like she by surprise okay
hi there I get it perfect leg Brian
Kelly
nope why me God bye whoa
look at that it's can so well dead uh
catch you by surprise do it okay yeah hi
there hi it's me oh god I'm so anxious
I'm so uh what happened to your eyebrows
yeah hi dad
sometimes he works so well I don't I
don't understand I want are the females
like doing this woman stop molesting my
girlfriend video game it'll be very
interesting to see my girlfriend in 20
years this might be it might be useful
knowledge nah NetID ah ah I like that
scar that she I mean it's you Meg see
you in 20 years time Mitzi what are you
doing Mitzi
well that's continued accent medic see
ya Oh God yeah crazy huh hi oh goodness
I mean thank you it's just you in 20
years time marker wasn't I you must be
angry god it's so creepy huh Ted uh what
happened to your beard man right yes it
is hi there hi it's me no it's you
now shut up ken you would never talk
British that's blasphemy let's try
Kermit the Frog way who's talking yeah
it's the skin man you know a stri steve
buscemi a beautiful son of a [ __ ] I
want to see him in a couple years I'm
Stevie looks like she bought your prizes
here
yes it did hi there I didn't think it
was possible I mean it looks even better
good to you this should be interesting
it's color my boy yeah it's boy Ted a
god girl like she by surprise
okay Aaron Paul it's a lovely face I'm
sure he will look beautiful in the
future Ted uh ha ha ha ha ha right hi
it's me hey it's you okay it's time
Aaron Paul look it wasn't yes you were a
turd all right breasts gonna have to
ended that maybe like if you do watch it
gets a scratch um birth today and I sold
it I'll see you in next one stay awesome
right